when I when I was young and was you know
first studying philosophy I think like a
lot of people I kind of I idealize and
idolize Socrates you know he's this
great thinker we all want to be
Socratic I mean I think he's still a
great thinker and still important but I
also think he's kind of an you
know um I don't think he's I kind of
agree with Aristotle this irony stuff um
sometimes it's really kind of a put on
you
know um why not just come out and say
what you actually do think and you know
why why didn't he take care of his kids
you know to me that's that's a big
problem um you get to say oh you know if
I can like get along with Zan thipe I
can get along with
anyone that seems like a terrible
idea for a marriage you know
I mean not to mention his his
interlocutors just accepting premises
that's like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're you're under no obligation to
accept that you can you know just I mean
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't there's there's some who do push
back right um in the early dialogues it
tends to be more oh yeah let me go along
with you Socrates I think in the
gorgus you know gorgus is kind of a
pushover but I don't think polus and
calicles are um we know certainly
is yeah yeah and and ion he's such a
nice guy he's willing to take Socrates
saying you don't have any idea what the
hell you're doing buddy you know yeah
like yeah I guess I
don't what a
surprise um but I mean that also shows
us something about the friendliness that
they they display you
know um I mean that would be an
interesting topic to to write WR about
so Aristotle's conception of
friendliness as we talked about you know
has to do with um setting limits um what
you're willing to let people say what
you're going to collaborate or cooperate
in and whether you're willing to give
people pain at the right time are some
of Socrates interlocutors too much of a
pushover like should Ian have
been um he's not obsequious right he's
not he's not butt kissing but he do he
he wants to get along and he thinks that
Socrates will be able to help him out
understanding his own art um should ion
have been more critical you know should
he push back with Glen and Adam mantis
right in book two of the Republic where
they're like um you know you you
dispatched through simus but you didn't
really deal with his points let me
reframe them this in a in a stronger way
you know and then they tag team
Socrates uh with something that they
don't even themselves believe in they
say this isn't my position but people
say this sort of stuff how would you
respond to it they're they're stronger
interlocutors but you know GL gl's
Plato's
brother you know so I mean who else
gives gives good push
back
um
I mean I don't think anybody in the
Symposium is but they're kind of
preoccupied with their own speeches no
um fedis Too Young in the fedis to do
much of anything yeah go ahead uh maybe
a
penist right oh right yeah young
Socrates he points out some problems
with the doctrine of the
forms um so that's one I mean does um
protagonists adequately push back
against Socrates the way the dialogue is
structured is more
like protagoras putting forth stuff and
then Socrates attacking it so maybe
not
um yeah it's you know the the really
good push back ones are kind of limited
we have the ones where it's not really
Socrates but somebody else presenting
the doctrine like the Athenian strange
or the um elatic stranger right I
remember when I was a a grad student
reading vindel Bond saying the laws uh
Plato's last and scile work you know and
it was often just dismissed as like ah
who wants to read this you know but
it's actually quite good yeah sure and
and and he certainly goes into much
greater depth about many topics that we
might be interested in from the earlier
dialogues in the laws I mean it's the
longest of of his pieces right so I
think it's kind of undervalued stock you
could say
um